[Musica]
[Applauso]
lei è la mia bisnonna Maria e oggi ha
102 anni io e lei abbiamo un rapporto
molto speciale di grande complicità
Insomma sono il suo nipote preferito
anche se non me lo ammetterà mai visto
che siamo otto pronipoti
come potete vedere dalla foto è seduta
di fronte a un piatto di pasta più
precisamente delle ruote al ragù Sì ho
ormai quasi 30 anni però le ruote al
ragù della vista le mangio ancora e
dovete sapere che fin da quando sono
piccolo il ragù a casa è la mia bisnonna
non mancava mai e il mio bisnonno il
Tonino il marito della bis le mangiava
sempre e rigorosamente con le
tagliatelle e per un po' anche io Poi
sai hai 6/7 anni e le tagliatelle è una
pasta lunga quindi sono complesse da
tirare su quella forchetta e il mio
grembiule delle elementari si sporcava
sempre
dico il mio perché la stessa cosa non
succedeva a mio fratello tre anni in più
ma lui il grembiule non si sporcava mai
così al terzo episodio la vista ha
trovato la soluzione più semplice e
pratica per ovviare a questo problema e
a pranzo a tavola ha fatto trovare non
solo per me ma per tutti le ruote al
ragù ruote pasta corta il mio grembiule
era Salvo mi ricordo che da piccolo ne
mangiavo tantissima facevo sempre il bis
facevo la scarpetta e in realtà non mi
sono mai domandato più di tanto cosa ci
fosse dentro quel piatto pensavo che
tutti avessero la stessa visione del
cibo in realtà se ci guardiamo intorno
Ognuno ha visione di cibo differenti
prendiamo ad esempio due tipologie
da una parte abbiamo Coloro che sono
presi dalla frenesia della vita
quotidiana e magari optano per un panino
al volo oppure per la schiscetta Anche
perché Considerate che tre italiani su 4
mangiano il pranzo a lavoro oppure c'è
chi opta Per un piatto surgelato oppure
ordinano dall'app di Delivery
Considerate che più del 45% degli
italiani ordina abitualmente dalle App
di Delivery e un altro dato che mi ha
fatto molto riflettere è che l'italiano
al supermercato passa meno di 30 minuti
Questo vuol dire che la convenienza e la
velocità diventano le priorità
principali a discapito della
consapevolezza alimentare e delle
qualità nel piatto
Dall'altra parte invece abbiamo i
cosiddetti turisti i puristi sono coloro
che sono alla costante ricerca di Sapori
conosciuti di sapori della loro terra
della loro tradizione
i puristi non si danno spazio a
sperimentare altre mix di ingredienti
altre culture Io ovviamente rispetto
ogni tipo di approccio al cibo Però
diciamo che quest'ultimo può un po' a
intaccare la creatività e la
sperimentazione
Considerate che più del 64% e gli
italiani ancora strettamente legato a
tutte quelle ricette considerate e
conservatrici mentre solo la restante
parte predilige quelle più sperimentali
Ma che cosa intendiamo in base a questi
dati la tradizione quindi può essere un
limite o un'opportunità
la tradizione può essere sia un limite
che un'opportunità dipende un po' dal
modo in cui l'affrontiamo da una parte
riservare la tradizione ci consente di
tramandarla alle future generazioni e
anche di preservare l'identità di una
nazione poi noi siamo molto Fieri della
nostra Patria dell'Italia Però
dall'altra parte era tradizione diventa
un po' troppo rigida può andare a
intaccare la creatività e la
sperimentazione di nuovi mix di
ingredienti e la scoperta di nuove
tecniche di cottura e anche di piatti
altrettanto gustosi
Ma che cosa intendiamo quando parliamo
di tradizione culinaria
la tradizione culinaria non si limita a
una ricetta da un manuale di cucina è
molto di più di questo ora vi chiedo di
provare a pensare Qual è il vostro
piatto della tradizione quello che
rievoca dentro di voi un senso di amore
e famiglia
Ecco probabilmente
quel piatto Non segue una ricetta ben
specifica Ma è stato plasmato dalle mani
amorevoli dei vostri genitori dei vostri
nonni a seconda dei vostri gusti
alimentari e delle risorse disponibili
pensate alle iconiche ruote al ragù
della mia bis ovviamente non segue la
ricetta classica del ragù alla bolognese
e sicuramente a Bologna non hanno mai
mangiato la pasta al ragù con le ruote
Almeno a me non è mai capitato però
quel piatto per me evoca un ricordo
importante ha un valore grandissimo fa
parte della mia di tradizione
la bellezza della tradizione risiede
appunto in questo nella sua flessibilità
è un terreno fertile per l'innovazione e
l'adattamento ogni cuoco anche quelli
più amatoriali come lo sto cercando di
diventare io possono dare il proprio
tocco personale a tutte quelle ricette
che definiremmo tradizionali Anzi se ci
pensate bene tutte le ricette
tradizionali sono nate Appunto così
la tradizione è sempre stata fluida non
è mai stata statica si è sempre evoluta
nel corso degli anni a seconda di
cambiamenti culturali di cambiamenti
sociali e ambientali pensate a tutte
quelle ricette iconiche della nostra
tradizione come la pasta alla carbonara
oppure la lasagna al ragù o la pizza
Ecco tutte quelle ricette in realtà sono
nate da un adattamento continuo nel
corso degli anni e sono diventati
iconiche invidiate in tutto il mondo
Partiamo dalla pizza
simbolo dell'Italia nel mondo Ora vi
chiedo
di provare a pensare a immaginare qual è
secondo voi la pizza originale ci siete
Ok Va bene Penso che ci siate Ok ve le
immaginate così
Ok anche io me lo immaginavo così eppure
lei è la mastunicola ed è una sorta di
antenata della nostra pizza margherita
che conosciamo tutti Adesso è fatta con
strutto basilico formaggio e pepe e tra
l'altro ho scoperto che in alcune
pizzerie storiche di Napoli La potete
ancora trovare io non ho ancora
sperimentato e poi c'è stata
un'evoluzione a questa pizza e voi
penserete alla margherita e invece no
perché sopra la mastunicola hanno
aggiunto delle minutaglie di pesce
sperimentavano un po' a Napoli ed è solo
alla metà del Settecento che arriva
lui il pomodoro il pomodoro è stato
importato al nuovo mondo e diciamo che
all'inizio non è stato accolto molto
bene molti pensavano che fosse velenoso
quindi non lo utilizzavano nelle varie
ricette e pietanze la paura del diverso
la paura del nuovo c'è sempre stata fin
dai tempi ma a Napoli hanno saputo
accogliere il pomodoro e da lì è nata la
pizza se si fossero fatti abbattere
dalla paura del velenoso pomodoro non
sarebbe nato quel piatto tanti conico e
che ci rappresenta nel mondo
Questa stessa ricetta della pizza è un
esempio in particolare che ci mostra
quanto la tradizione è sempre stata
fluida è sempre stata in grado di
accogliere nuovi ingredienti nuovi mix
di culture nuovi Sapori e poi col
pomodoro in Italia ne abbiamo fatte di
cose e la ricetta della pizza ha un
mezzo di comunicazione potentissimo
tutti conosciamo la pizza
poi ovviamente per me la pizza è
rigorosamente doppia mozzarella con le
patatine fritte meste dopo la cottura
probabilmente ogni volta il pizzaiolo mi
odia ma io la mangio solo patatine
oppure magari per qualcuno di voi è
quattro formaggi oppure con il salame
piccante e sicuramente in America sarà
con i peperoni che non sono i nostri
peperoni ma è tipo il loro salame oppure
con l'ananas
ma tutti viene in mente Un'unica cosa
una serata in compagnia la condivisione
il comfort Food per eccellenza Quanto è
potente il cibo
la sua capacità di andare oltre barriere
culturali barriere linguistiche barriere
temporali e generazionali mi sorprende
ogni volta pensiamo all'Italia quanti
Sapori ho ignorato e quanti in realtà
devo ancora conoscere ogni regione ha le
sue peculiarità culinarie che riflettono
la geografia però lo stesso piatto
cambia di provincia in provincia di casa
in casa di comune in comune ogni piatto
funge da Ponte territoriale e
generazionale quando prepariamo una
ricetta della nostra tradizione in
realtà ci colleghiamo a chi ci ha
preceduto i nostri genitori i nostri
nonni diventano di custodi di tutti
questi greti culinari e facendo le
nostre ricette andiamo ancora di più a
rafforzare il legame e l'identità della
famiglia
mangiare nutrirsi di ricordi di emozioni
di condivisioni di amore va oltre il
semplice saziarsi
Io ho scelto di aprire il mio cuore e la
mia mente a sperimentare nuove ricette
abbracciando il nuovo ma senza
dimenticare le mie radici
e oggi la tavolata della vite non ha
solo le tante coniche ruote al ragù che
io amo tanto ma sicuramente tanti altri
piatti tanti altri ricordi e tante altre
emozioni
da oggi vi invito a provare a cambiare
la vostra visione del cibo vi invito a
provare quel piatto che non avete mai
avuto il coraggio di provare io tipo
Poco fa ho provato i cavoletti di
Bruxelles devo dire che sono buoni ve li
consiglio e da oggi vi invito a provare
a vedere la tradizione non come un
limite ma come un'opportunità
e vi invito a sperimentare nuove ricette
nuovi mix di ingredienti e chissà magari
sarete voi a scoprire il prossimo
pomodoro e rivoluzionare la cucina
italiana
[Applauso]
[Musica]